junge warum sagst du mir das denn die
sache richtig viele transport patch gold
habe ich nicht gesagt so gesagt spiel
zurück dann macht pause ins spiel zurück
geht auch nicht herrn bock egal
hast du gesagt oder beim sex
das wichtig hoppel poppel herbert über
bürsten kann den ganzen erster
kommentaren und den antworten so ich
finde erster kommentare mittlerweile gar
nicht mehr so schlimm ich fände es viel
schlimmer
das dann immer sagt die mutter du und du
nicht bist du ja genauso schlimm ist
da fand von anfang an so
ich fand erster kommentare nie schlimm
aussah als arzt der total aus 23 24 26
das finde ich nicht so schlimm wenn man
23 der stadt also ich finds männer der
23 immer noch erster schreibt ja wo ich
schon ein bisschen facebook so scheffold
fußball mails meine meinung ist dazu
fähig so ich habe 46 kommission genie
was ist das
darf nicht sagen wo ich bin war sonst
weiß nicht vielleicht wo ich bin
jeweils ich eh nicht sag mal auf jeden
fall was anderes ich weiß nicht wer
vielleicht komme
das war was wollte wieso hab ich
aussehen müssen auch etwas noch mal gold
machen was nochmal gebracht das gold
gebracht hat
ja solche goldmann für gold kontakte fe
gold einfach noch nicht kontakt das
diesen für strom
so
ist noch da ich bin noch da her man weiß
es bei dir nicht manchmal sagt sie mir
gar nicht sollte wollte golden transport
pipe okay dafür brauche ich noch bleibe
brauche ich auch manchmal so damit hat
mir damals einfach alles zu pendelt
gemacht
was hab ich das ding wird sie ihnen wie
zurück machen kann oder so sieht man
dich du bist gar nicht da hab ich denke
dass bei dir immer denkt dass bei die
hre machte ich auch bei dir da los bei
dir ich kann gar nicht verstehen kann
gar nicht verstehen
richtig nervig ja manchmal die nerven
voll alter ja solche gelder soll
walter j albiol macht das mal er denn
mal ordentlich gemacht ist mach das
einfach nicht ordentlich gespart hast du
eigentlich wenn ihr selbst wenn selbst
displays was ich mache mich selbst auch
noch manchmal sagt mega-party kaputt
mache ich ja überhaupt nicht mehr
alleine weil da habe ich das machen soll
wieder ein haus gebaut aber zurzeit
mache ich dann einfach die komplette
wüst ist einfach leer gegrast lief ich
jetzt auch alles voll mit kurbel
achterbahn mit dem zauberstab
wahrscheinlich dann ach mensch da komme
ich mit meiner schaufel an 83 jolo meine
curry wird gerade gebaut
nee wenn ich mich gar nicht mehr alleine
auf mega projekt ist immer wenn ich
etwas mache dann bin ich so vertieft
sondern mehr reden dann müssen anderen
reden geben dass ich bin auch manchmal
ein paar tage um zu probieren da weiß
einfach nicht wie das geht mit bob miner
meine passion hier die gerade einfach
mal sonst entwickelt dagegen okay gut
danke aber bis heute knochen okay leute
dass meine krieg gebaut hast du hast du
ich hab ja ich hatte schon was mein
könig gebaut wird wie es funktioniert
nicht mehr so sauer
ja ich brauche jetzt erst mal an julia
einfach mal ob das funktioniert ich mir
vorstellen in dem ich eine long bonds
sensoren verwarnt und jetzt mache
scheiße glas für den 4
weil sie mir gedacht habt gut doch
trotzdem kurz von dem baum um ihr
schalter zu machen weil ich die
natürlich vergessen absdorf bin alter
manchmal denke ich muss an die
elektriker engines muss ich schalte
ansetzen damit überhaupt funktionieren
ach so korrekt eine glas stört mich
jetzt dass das einst von items und dann
nochmal 1 ja das ist einfach so
förster problems bei stoff leiten vorbei
er wird schon gebaut
ok dann kommt nämlich noch hier
electricals engine rein und unterhalt
auch noch mit ihnen gott ach ich hatte
da noch ganz viel glas drin auch ich bin
ja du bist du dumm reichen 46 golden
bleibt je nachdem wie groß das daten so
du brauchst golden peaks der ganztag
weise golden peaks gemacht du brauchst
richtig wenig nur man weiß nicht 20
stück oder so ähnlich von coop junge
warum sagst du mir das denn du sagst mir
macht richtig viele transport park
school habe ich nicht gesagt so gesagt
spiel zurück ich kann ich zurückschaue
dann nach hause zurück geht auch nicht
herr bock egal
hast du gesagt ich hab drei stacks das
ist ja so blöd alter also das ist echt
dumm von mir selber keine ahnung davon
nicht extrem viel das stimmt ich weiß
nicht in welchem zusammenhang ich das
gesagt da wollte
baust du dir erstmal so viel regnet
alter egal da mach ich halt alles mit
golden platz dann läuft bei mir extrem
schnell
ja du brauchst aber nicht mehr so viele
durch stelter nur ein paar kisten rahmen
man du stellst du aber wenn du um direkt
ab und so was alles ja dann vielleicht
ja die sind es nicht total umsonst aber
im moment brauchst auf jeden fall gar
nicht so viel
dann mach ich mir jetzt so la la ola
jetzt nochmal solarpanels dafür
bräuchten menge kohle das menge glas ja
gut dann meine ganze sonst
jahre bis zum 100 papaya sagt der
richtige
was wenn ich so viel rabatt gegeben
ich brauche was dumm nur wieso bin ich
doch ich bin nett navis haben uns das
bonner von schweina simon geschenk gut
okay
electronics werke die brauche ich glaube
ich auch elektronik circuit
ich hasse wassereinbrüche aus aber kann
man nur kompakter machen
da fällt mir voll gut aber nicht nur zur
zeit im vergleich zu den nach köln auf
den tischen danach meine fresse aktuelle
tricks völker
wer ist die nummer tricks so es kann
auch ein paar klare glas lieber kabel
läuft der scheiße kop kop kop cable so
was meinte ich brauche ich das gesagt
von richtig viele koffer kevin er breuer
für die ganze sogar eher gut
ich habe zu wenig tracks alter schon
dumm alter richtig sturm pfleger das
wäre die dom cobb sein es reicht gerade
so gut da kommt immer freunde
ich glaube ich kann da nämlich jetzt
einfach den mlp draufsetzen
aber das wird um afrika abbauen
jawohl wir mussten nämlich der ausgang
zeigt dahin wo ich gucke ist am block
nämlich darüber sitzen da kommt der
strom raus das kann werken jetzt meine
solar power alter mensch nehme aber auch
noch eineinhalb eineinhalb stunden auf
ok
ok ich weiß dass hier im ghetto
da wird und ich nachts wäre dann würde
das ganze hier schon laufen stattdessen
läuft noch nicht aber dabei gleich noch
mal ran sale egal dass auch das passt
auch so okay so das produziert als strom
das geht alles rein mm f stop cooking
das gilt als reine federleicht schon
weiterhin stromkreislauf der geringen
sachen hier
er braucht aber noch die dinger hier
müssen an sein
ich hoffe die sind an wir sind als
erstes auf jeden fall mal aus das heißt
schon mal wie sein dass wenn sie an sind
alle neu hin dass schon kleine eine
fackel den ist auch jolo alter so eine
fackel juli macht die beiden auf jeden
fall an
und dann habe ich nur noch zwei personen
nämlich die beide sollen das heißt es
kann weg und stellt es eine fackel den
sorgen alle weg
die cablecom krims krams scheiße hier
naja man kann es sind sachen und
touristische mit mit irgendetwas anderes
da sieht man mal wie kaputt weil ihr es
schon erfahrungen abgaben 80 noch die
ganzen sachen nicht mehr mit reg wenn
man mit shift aus dem ofen und sowas ist
voll durch das auch schnell abgewöhnt
ich auch es gibt immer kein xp aber ist
mir egal ob es mehrere guardiola
okay ich bin hier fertig ist muss man
auf den track draufsetzen und zum
funktionieren bekommen sagt drauf wie
heißen das ganze ding da query
corey perry conny und weitere cent
online elektronik habe ich dann brauche
ich jetzt noch okay eigentlich
funktioniert das scheiß dingwerth
funktioniert nicht ich würde sagen ich
geh nach hause und wenn ich zu hause
anwenden dann dann kommen wir mal ob es
funktioniert es sollte funktionär nicht
funktioniert
ich hab noch 81
ja du brauchst richtig viele schon ein
bisschen abkühlung bei dir auch so heißt
bei mir jetzt nicht ausgestellt ich
meine es ist bei uns hat heute welt
gehagelt ernsthaft zu erwarten ist ball
grosse hagelkörner ohne scheiß keiner
nicht so kalt sein
sie galten so was bildet doch das hat
sich unglaublich schnell abgekühlt die
klage kam und dann ist direkt
geschmolzen auf dem boden das wasser war
groß im bild bei instagram gepostet die
opfer tschuldigung habe ich nicht
gesehen
doch du bist schon an einem ort eingeben
bei uns gab es mir überhaupt die ja
schon haben wir so voll wie bitte wir
haben damals vorlauf vorgemacht und text
und foto und ganz anderen sinn so extrem
schnell leer das ist so dumm probleme
ich bin mittlerweile schon so wenig
energie am haben
was für ein deutsch das meine ich hab
gar keiner erfährt kernenergie weihnacht
das was man denn bitte natürlich kam
nach hause
ein experte hat keine energie frage
warum guckt man se 24 ja ich bin gerade
auf dem weg nach hause ich dass man
irgendwo rein fallen weil meine rüstung
hat keine energie mehr und dann ist man
immer von einem männchen der perfekte
scheiß petric für mein team im moment da
ich sehe im gotteshaus war schon das
festige haus von anderen leuten dass ich
noch nicht draußen gar kein haus ja ein
schönes haus und grundstück direkt
daneben aber hier ist ein schönes haus
tag rein und schlafe ich hab richtig box
und richtig jetziges haus zu bauen als
alle sich aufregt vor allem du jolo
guten ich war echt dein als social und
du hast einfach aber ich versteh ich das
ist doch darum macht man so etwas erst
regnet es direkt bei mir dass es nur
weil dort aufgewachsen und jetzt aufhört
auf jeden fall gibt jetzt eigentlich
strom das heißt wenn hier untergeht dann
müsst ihr da eigentlich erstmals auch
aufladen
weil es kein unten aufladen
da eigentlich müsste das nämlich view
mit der presse ich eigentlich massig
platz absolut so hier sollte ein stunden
langsam was rauskommen
das ding ist ich kann das noch gar nicht
einschätzen aber etwas kommt oder nicht
weil ich hier erst so das ist hier dass
der moment wahrscheinlich so durchs
wasser und es dauert ewig bis er denn
die ersten oberen blog alle weg hat aber
egal wenn sich die sache einfach
funktioniert wenn er die folgen wenn ich
pech gehabt so ist das halt viel spaß
viel lang zuschauen viel spaß luca noch
beim fällen und dann gehen wir und alter
ich konnte gerade quantums verdoppeln
doch nicht schade irgendwie komisch
gewesen